if an open border
that is currently in an invasion that is
being led by a satanic criminal cartel
called MS-13 among other cartels if that
is not a good use of the American
Military what is the point of the
American Military
we the American Military everywhere in
the world we can't put them on the
southern border no no we can't the real
reason why we can of course is that
the elites don't want that because the
elites want an open border because the
Democrats want more voters and the
Republicans want cheap labor at least
the Chamber of Commerce Republicans who
have lost a lot of a lot of influence in
the Republican party but that's why if
they wanted to fix that problem they
could fix it in two seconds but the
language they dress it up is the
language of Mercy for these people okay
well that's that would be uh that would
be big government yeah government exists
within its proper limits if this is not
within the proper limits of government
the government does not exist